news daily from science mission
scientists generated induced neural
progenitor cells from neonatal and adult
peripheral blood using single factor
opted for reprogramming and by adding
inhibitors these / generators were
differentiated both in vivo and in vitro
producing astrocytes oligodendrocytes
and multiple neuronal subtypes including
dopaminergic neurons of CNS and not
susceptible neurons of peripheral
nervous system next researchers
discovered that Celeste all excited from
the route of thunder god vine plant is a
powerful anti-obesity agent celestron
suppresses food intake blocks reduction
of energy expenditure and leads up to
forty-five percent weight loss in
hyperlipidemic diet-induced obese mice
by increasing leptin sensitivity but it
is ineffective in leptin deficient
leptin receptor deficient mouse models
next when scientists mutated the whole
genome of measles virus only mutations
at places other than outer glycoprotein
survive this an elastic property of
glycoproteins which are required to
enter the cells and against which the
vaccines are developed thus becomes easy
target since the mutated versions cannot
survive for more details visitors at ww
w science mission calm are our science
mission facebook page thanks for
watching